[Musique]
on va aller dans une région où les gens
sont beaucoup plus sage
je crois qu'il respecte les quotas il ya
là-bas quelqu'un qui nous a fait vibrer
à travers des séries noires mais qui
adore aller se mettre au vert dans cette
région que je connais bien qui s'appelle
la creuse
voici un portrait très rustique de
victor lanoux à paris quand je lui en
veux tu en vises finir et de revenir si
j'ai quelquefois je suis dit mon film
vendredi à 18 heures 18h10 ou dans la
voiture et quatre heures plus tard
chelsea
vous pouvez chercher dans le
dictionnaire à gartempe et vous lirez
rivière réputé pour ses truites enfance
assez fermé bien souvent kutcher a
laissé passer pas d'activité c'est un
mets loisirs pour vous rien victor
lanoux dans son propre personnage
une épreuve pour le comédien plus à
l'aise dans les compositions
il a choisi de nous présenter son
village de la creuse comme l'amour fou
j'imagine cette prime le temps qui nous
font réparer sa dette a dû être pris
ceux du receveur des deux murs pont du
pire en tout cas combien de chansons on
voit bien d'ailleurs comment il le fait
et a pas moins de ciment maçons creusois
il n'y a plus rien du tout vous voyez
vous tombez dans les villages là ici
il ya belle plus une vache laitière
temps pour ce village avait
jusqu'à 500 habitants il ya 50 ans il en
compte 200 aujourd'hui
avec certainement 75% de deux retraités
savez ça veut bien dire ce que ça veut
dire
on peut pas on peut pas être insensible
à cela la survie du monde rural c'est la
survie de la vie purement et simplement
si on fait parce qu est ce qui doit être
fait c'est vrai que ça m'ouvre à messi
le monde rural meurent tous noura
[Musique]
j'ai dit il ya une passe sautée ap
vienne france hier l'ong qui pense à
vous je vois plus clair sur sa lancée et
c'est l'école c'est comme tous les
gamins c'est une odeur c'est ce les
sentiers césar bleynie qu'on déniche
pour vous mais lance pierres qu'on se
fabriquent les rigolades sur les tas de
foin enfin comme tous les enfants de la
campagne fois je crois que ça n'a rien
d'exceptionnel mais vous n'êtes pas
rester ici vous êtes revenu survenu
après ouais j'ai été il se place est ici
par l'assistance le public et je suis
revenu après ce que j'adorais be j'ai
adoré ce pays que j'ai eu besoin du
revenu croit que les passages les
chemins qu'on emprunte pendant pendant
la prime enfance gestede les traces
indélébiles
je crois beaucoup à l'importance de la
prime enfance dans le destin d'un
individu est clair
cette région j'ai joué j'ai tout fait
pour elle
j'ai été adopté par elle il ya très
longtemps et je me sens bien quoi c'est
m6 c'était une mère adoptive mais qui
meurent est quand même enfanter et puis
et puis aussi parce qu'en dehors de sa
beauté
c'est que c'est un pays vérité c'est à
dire que c'est un pays pauvre
curieusement on notera que plus on se
rapproche rapproche de la communauté
plus on s'approche avait invité parce
que parce que aussi bien les choses le
paysage que les êtres ne sont pas
polluées par par l'argent
l'intérêt puis les hameçons vrai dire
que les amis ici sont des la plupart des
paysans ou des paysans prêter
qui parle vrai je me j'aime bien le
parler vrai
[Musique]
on a quand même une richesse les
pâturages on a de l'eau on à l'herbe et
puis on a une res vaches extraordinaire
c'est celle là
la limousine
[Musique]